I actually hear me during my class.
We're like, yeah, so like I should say stuff like this.
It's the real deal, it's just the real deal.
And then I was like, it wasn't a test, it was real.
It was real.
Wait, now you have to say that for real though.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Yeah.
Woo, everybody's a surprise!
Woo!
And then later I was like, okay, are we getting viewed?
I'm sweating for the queue!
I don't know.
Can you guys see us?
No!
This is real now.
This is real.
No more tests.
It's happening.
Hello, how are you with Sherry?
Welcome.
Welcome to the Phantom Thief Paddle, everyone.
Yay!
Isn't that what the panel is called?
What is this called?
It is called fantasy.
What the fuck do you mean?
Doki, there's babies here!
Oh, sorry, what the heck do you mean?
I forgot there's people walking behind.
Yeah, I literally saw people walking behind you guys.
Should we, maybe just in case there's somebody that's like,
who are these obnoxious anime women?
I don't know, I know who just swore in front of children.
I am a bad influence.
Her parents did not let their kids watch me.
Obviously Doki's streams are 18 plus.
Yeah, yeah, my streams are 18 plus.
Exactly the reasons you think.
Men's channel is for children, for kids.
Yeah, we're Muppets.
You guys are like Coco Melon.
Coco Melon.
You guys like you guys like that, yeah.
Yeah, woo, Coco Melon.
What does a Coco Melon do?
people doing six seven in the front of the yeah yeah yeah
it's just because my arms are like this i can't help i'm
really doing it right now i started the trend i started you
were the original child yeah the other child sold from you
right who started it i don't even know okay okay I'm Doki
Brain and then who are you?
I couldn't even hear what your intro was.
Good, don't listen to me.
Oh, I mean I rarely do, but...
You barely listen to anything.
Yeah, I don't even listen to myself.
It goes from one ear to the other.
I just go with it.
They're great.
For real.
Yeah, yeah, it's just all vibes.
All vibes.
We have pure instinct and vibes.
Yeah.
doing a Q&A for you guys so if you guys have any questions
or you might not have we might not have the answers to them
but you know it'll be fun to just hang out and talk to all
the dragoons and the boo-boo no it's not saying no the crowd
goes miles stop making it because they don't want to be
called that they're like please don't let her name us no I
veto I veto it you veto it Yeah, but you only get one veto
You can't veto the other That's how vetoes work Why would
you have votes?
Why can't I have unlimited veto?
Because then it's not a democratic vote That's just your
vote Danny, are you there?
Hi, I'm here I was waiting for your cue But I guess I missed
it It's okay, we didn't get a cue either Amazing You're just
here Hi guys, I'm Danny, also known as Danny Sores.
I'm one of the cosplay guests with K2B, and I'm super
excited to be here and host the Phantom Thief panel.
So anyways, if you have a question, we will have a line down
this center column here, and we will have these two lovely
gentlemen here to review your questions.
Please, be respectful.
You know, you know the drill.
They look like- No, they look like bodyguards.
They look like bouncers, you know?
Jojo pose, Jojo pose.
I was like, they're bouncers, bodyguards, and babysitters
all at once, so.
Wait, who's the baby?
Is it me?
I'm the baby, I'm the baby.
I'm the baby.
Lovely, lovely.
So if you have a question, please feel free to come line up,
ask your Oshis what you want, just know they're judging you,
so don't be too weird.
That's one of the types of clubs, if they're bouncers, it's
types of clubs where we judge your outfit too, if you're
It's good enough to get in.
We'll get ratings out of 10.
Chats to get in the front of the line.
And anyways, Mint Doki, are you ready for your first
question?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, let's go.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hi, Mint.
Hi, Doki.
Hey.
This is a question for Mint specifically.
Okay.
Oh, sorry.
I'm sorry.
When...
You mentioned that you met Vinny at a MGS pop-up store.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
And Vinny is like one of my favorite Fleshcubers.
So I was wondering if you would be open to collabing with
him one of these days.
I think so.
Because Nymo knows him.
So I feel, well, I guess I met him.
I don't know.
I would.
I don't know what we do.
Want to just talk?
I have to talk to Flesh people.
you're doing it right now yeah i say yes because i like his
glitch his glitch runs they're fine yeah so yes yes oh so hi
again hi do you want to rate his outfit oh he's got the
phantom beef oh yeah the bag you showed me yesterday and the
sir okay yes spin spin nice very good do a walk do the
naruto run
Thank you so much for your question.
Now we'll have our next question.
Hello, both of you.
Hi!
Here's a quick question for Mint.
Oh, what's your favorite Metal Gear game?
Well, Doki, yours would be Delta, right?
I mean, that's the only game I play.
I mean, I did play the, was it Metal Gear Rising?
Oh, Rising, yeah.
Yeah, yeah.
I still, I don't know.
I like the, I haven't figured out which one's better yet.
Because I have, I felt like I was mostly watching a movie
for the- That's so true.
I like Metal Gear Solid 2.
Why?
Why too?
It was the reason.
Well, if you played the game, you would understand.
Like, oh, don't you burn.
Like, you're just gonna say 2 and not explain, like, what
Kojima did that made 2 the best one.
Okay, who, raise your hand if you play 2.
Okay, you understand, right?
nod your head.
I saw people who didn't raise their hands, but they don't
understand.
You gotta give context to why you pick two.
Raise your hand.
Who loves spoilers?
Raise your hand if you watch someone play two.
So there's still some hands that didn't raise up.
There's still some hands.
How do I explain two?
The Patriots.
That's that's all.
amazing thank you so much we actually wanted you to have an
entire powerpoint presentation of why metal gear solid 2 was
your favorite metal gear solid game but we'll save that for
another day and we'll have an extra panel today i had
homework i had homework that you should have made a panel
what is your cause oh wait you're smiling friends yes oh my
god it's him
Hi!
So I have a question.
Yeah.
So I know both of you guys, you guys like to laugh a lot.
So what is the best knockout moments that you guys have?
Oh my god.
So many.
I can't even...
Wait, I have one from recently.
I have one from literally like the other night when you were
playing and...
Oh, is it a crocodile?
It was when you were like swimming and I was like, I think
you're gonna drown.
And you were like, I'm gonna drown.
Yeah, that one was good.
Also, that one was my favorite.
When we were playing the, we did the Sloppy Sisters Club and
we played the fireworks game and we launched the nuke.
Oh, hey, I was like, hey guys, I think I found a nuke.
And then right after.
What about you?
No, I think the nuke one was my favorite, too.
I was like, I wonder what happens when we die.
activate a nuclear bomb guys nothing nothing bad could
happen nothing bad could happen surely yeah no that one was
also my favorite what about yours what's your favorite any
well from yesterday no not you I'm talking to oh from Kim oh
okay please we say you I ought to make excuse that you're
talking about me I say
full government named Doki Bird.
Yeah, Doki the bird.
Do you have a favorite?
He's thinking.
Oh, while he's thinking, I can share my favorite.
You guys want to hear that?
Yeah!
So about one year ago, I attended a Phantom Thief concert in
Atlanta.
Amazing.
You guys...
A year ago, like most recently.
Yeah.
Your performance was so good.
I freaked out, I was so excited, and that was the moment I
decided I was cosplaying both of you to Off-Kai.
What the one moment that made me laugh so hard is that Doki
was playing Marvel Rivals at the start of the concert and It
was just so on-brand and your banter was hilarious, and I'll
forever remember that memory in my heart, so What do you
remember?
Concert canceled.
Time for Marvel Rivals.
It's time to play Marvel Rivals, everyone.
Cossack canceled.
I've got a play rake.
And, you know, he can't think of a moment.
There's just too many.
You're still full of fun and laughter.
So we'll actually just head on to our next question.
Okay, thank you.
Hi.
Hi, Minton.
Mint, remember how you got the Metal Gear Solid 4 pachinko
machine and how we all knew about it?
Oh, sorry.
Metal Gear Solid 3, pachinko machine.
By bad.
Actually.
I don't know.
Never played the games.
Never watched the games.
of Metal Gear Iron Zone.
Never once did you just do about your fun fact, man.
Just...
You're so honest, I appreciate that.
But the thing is, since you got Joke Bird into Metal Gear
Solid Delta, when you get to have her have a go at the Metal
Gear Solid and just be...
Oh, you want to go over?
Oh, yeah, let's do it.
Wait, do you still have it?
Yeah, I haven't.
Oh, shit, yeah, I'll be able to try it.
Okay.
You have to use real money?
No, no.
I mean, are you...
Yes, actually.
Yeah, like I come over like we're just gambling at Mintz
House.
I withdraw the money and then I keep it.
That's how it works.
You speak to the stream, please.
Thank you.
We get a stream?
Oh, we could probably.
We could probably do that.
Who else would love to see that as a stream?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
What if I just get like bird wings?
Just like gallons of bird wings.
And on to our next question.
I love that we have one urm actually moment of this panel
already so and here we go hi hey Doki hey boss so I have
come here with a very important question to ask you and
that's can God heat up a burrito so hot that he himself
could not touch it have you ever he heated up a burrito no I
haven't heated a burrito there's no like Mexican restaurants
in Canada okay but like but like it's but like it's very
rare to find a good one it's like I I know what God has
feared I know I have heated up the burrito and it is pulled
on the outside and then it becomes so hot inside that you're
like I I don't I there's this is unlevel levels of high that
I feel like it is literally the center of the earth covering
it so that the heat is evenly distributed.
No.
Right.
It's like, um, I don't feel like that doing that.
That's a bit too much work.
Getting a cover to put on top of your burrito, too much
work.
Just stick it in the microwave.
I got this.
I'm in a rush.
That's why I'm microwaving it.
Anyways, thank you so much for your questions.
And on to our next question.
and third friendly neighborhood Florida man here so one of
the things I like about that we were just saying oh my god
you you met the whole family yeah we were like we met the
Florida sister the Florida brother yeah the Florida Roman
the Florida kids so one of the things I like to do on my
free time during the weekend is I'll ride my bike over to
the beach and then once I'm there at the I'll just go for a
walk.
So I don't know if you guys would call yourselves out there
as people, but like if you were to go walking somewhere,
what kind of scenery would you be going for?
Like woods, would you like to go to the beach, jungle, crown
town?
Are you just trying to get our dating profile?
Like, I'm on walks on the beach.
Camping in the jungle.
I mean, if you're offering.
Oh!
I mean, I'll take you with all that.
We're being in a room with four walls and air conditioning
or heat.
I want to be an urban explorer.
Oh, I'm going to go to abandoned places.
I look.
Oh my God.
You can die from the mud.
I'm already dead.
Oh yeah, that's true.
like the most the most biggest fear like the black mold oh
wait your apartment has black mold yeah yeah so it's fun
yeah so you're having i'm inviting you over you're inviting
me over to experience the black mold yeah well yeah i think
an ideal first date would be like going to an abandoned mall
seeing if there's any still water there oh yeah and then
going into the still water making sure there's like
brain-eating amoebas in there like it's like the tombstone
that was oh but like they can't really eat anything there's
nothing inside that was a lovely roast I appreciate it oh
you were talking about weight and I love that your ideal
location became a dating profile question awesome thank you
so much thank you and also I love that uh this IRL pachinko
stream will have doki experiencing her worst fear of black
mold oh nice why did you not get that big it's been like
you've been there for years I used to know black mold I
don't know anyways on to our next question
What has been your favorite moment in Metal Gear so far?
So far.
I know, I know what your favorite moment is.
I know what your favorite moment is.
Which one?
No, I don't know.
I don't know.
I'm like, I know.
I know.
Okay, what is my favorite moment?
It's what he meowed.
Yeah.
Okay, actually, I think my favorite moment is when I
realized that no, that's is that is your thing don't like
place it on to me that's you I think I think it's like it's
what is I have two favorite moments so far it's when like
when we when we had the mascot the frog and the duck mask
and we found out there's no aisles in it yeah because I was
like okay let's go let's let's shoot this guy and then like
like you know first person yeah first person like we're in
the aisle eye holes.
And then my second favorite is when I went over to Ocelot
and I shot him and then you're like, you created a time.
I was like, why can't I kill him?
I don't even know.
Was there even part of the story you did that?
I was trying to change the course of history.
And then to my first favorite.
Oh, sorry.
Continue.
Yeah.
No, we already know her favorite meow part.
She tried to push it.
out of me but the other one is where I get to learn about
the Cold War thanks to jumbo history lesson yeah it's
history lessons with go jumbo yeah all right what's your
favorite moment other than the cat meow I can't say you are
you just got into snake eater oh that's true it might spoil
I feel like I wouldn't understand the context if you do tell
it I like when the end does his speech right before you
fight him.
It's my favorite part.
Who's he?
Oh, the New York City guy?
No, old man.
Also, I like when Vulcan grabs his croc.
Way too many people nodded there.
Yeah.
Consensus for the color?
Yes, you know?
Yes.
He's got to show the people what he has.
Right.
Thank you so much.
And now we will go on to our next question.
Well, I just have a simple question.
Are there any games you want to stream but haven't gotten
around to doing it yet?
I have so many.
All right, you go first then.
I want to stream Alan Wake.
Wait, is that the...
Oh, Alan Wake at the lake?
Yeah, that's the...
That's the same, right?
Wait, I can't even John Wick mixed up.
Okay, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
No, John Wick does not have a game.
Don't worry.
I know.
Oh, yeah, I want to see that.
I want to stream near.
Oh, that's a long-term commitment.
That theme is so long.
Yeah.
What about you?
Me?
Yeah.
Oh, that is hard.
There is a lot of games I do want to play.
I want to do Heroes of Might and Magic.
And also, oh, Club Penguin.
I've yet to stream Club Penguin.
From Club Penguin.
We can do the dance.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
remember when we tried to record the Club Penguin dance and
then the footage was lost forever.
It was lost forever!
Yeah, they're like fandom people, we recorded it.
We recorded the Club Penguin dance but then it disappeared.
The record, like the public was not meant to see it.
Maybe one day we can re-record it again.
Yeah, we can re-record it again, yeah.
Oh.
Sorry, technical difficulties and I'm sure we're all waiting
for you to re-record that truly and Doki we would love to
see you play games outside of Marvel rivals that would be
awesome too I barely played the game yesterday yeah you were
you were paid to do that and great defense and on to our
next question Hi.
This is really a question.
I watch Mouse a lot.
So I know both of you from Mouse and I wanted to say, Min,
you were so good at her concert.
I was so excited that I could stream it.
And Doge, I just want to say congratulations in your win
from Marvel Rivals when they did the competition.
It was so fun to watch it.
Like, I don't normally watch normal Marvel Rise levels a
whole lot, so watching it was really entertaining and seeing
you, like, just your whole team, how they, like, just
completely smashed everything was so crazy to me.
So I just want to say thank you so much.
Oh, thank you!
Thank you!
Yay, that was amazing.
I also watched the concert, Mint, and you were amazing, so.
I have a concert tonight, you guys.
And I get a really, really loud cheer of everyone who's
going to the concert tonight.
And if any of you didn't cheer and you're not going, now you
know there's a concert after this at 4pm, so make sure you
attend.
It'll be amazing.
And if you're not going there, I'm doing a Project Zomboid
lady.
You guys want to join my Project Zomboid survey?
I'm just going to kill you.
She's gonna kill us all!
Everyone's at the concert watching the stream, the project's
on her screen.
We'll put it up in the corner, like, like, like, um, what's
the, how do they do with the chill, like a family guy
episode while the concert's happening.
Yeah, yeah, and then there's projects on foot on the corner.
Cocoa melon during the concert, you know?
Anyways, next question.
Hello!
Hi, Doki!
Hi, Minky.
Good to see y'all.
Hi!
Hello!
Oh!
I'm gonna throw you all in...
What's it called?
A pirate mob.
All right.
What do you think is the biggest animal you can take in a
fight?
The biggest animal I can take in a fight?
Like, fight them?
Like, actually beat them up?
Like, if you have to...
You have to choose the...
Like, it's life or death.
And you can have...
It's life or death.
And you have to pick the biggest animal you can take in a
fight.
Me versus 100 gorillas.
It's like that's that Pokemon thing where it's like who
would win?
One legendary Pokemon are a hundred lions.
I would win.
You would win against a hundred gorillas.
Put it through the simulator.
Yeah.
Put it through the animal simulator.
What about you, Doki?
All right.
If you're going to do a hundred gorillas, you're a bird.
Like you have sticks and stones for your bones.
You can't even fight!
You just face through them!
Not even a fight at that point!
I would fight...
Oh, that's hard.
Why would I make it harder for myself, though?
Like, why can't I just be like 100 ants and they'll just
like burn them through and magnify that?
They would be able to lift you up because you're so...
Oh yeah, yeah, because their ants can lift up X amount of
their body to 100 of them?
You have to be able to fly, right?
I can't just burn them with a magnifying glass.
I will fight a hundred ants.
What if it's nighttime?
It's nighttime?
When your power is like quarreling with the moon?
When the full moon is out, the ant's power gets stronger by
20 times.
No, you're talking about using a magnifying glass.
You're idiot.
But the moonlight!
The moonlight!
The moonlight shall intensify into the sun.
glass okay anyways thank you so much I love the disparity
between a hundred gorillas and a hundred ants I know a
little bit of a size difference you know but and our next
question hello so my question is actually for Cookie what
the hell ashes come on I'm gonna talk to you tomorrow you
dogster in front of everyone Whoa!
No, ask your question!
Ask your question to Doki Bird!
No, I'm not even listening!
Shush!
I'm not even here!
Wow!
That's right, it's the Doki Bird show now.
Anyway, hello Doki.
First, long time watch her, first time ask her.
So, Mint obviously is really in the idol groups.
My question is, has she gotten you into any idol groups?
And if so, get out of here!
And if so, which groups?
you which groups have you been listening to thanks to her oh
she has not man how come you haven't introduced me to any
idol groups man oh my god you love idols so much yet you
won't share any idol groups with me okay you don't follow me
on Twitter then because I'm literally yes I want to
personally share it to me you Okay, okay, I'll share some
with you.
All right, give me one item here right now.
Dempagumi Inc.
Wait, okay, that's real, okay.
I thought you were, I was like, wait, that's real?
Okay, how do you smell it?
Can you lift me up now so I can get back on this thing?
Okay, get over here.
We'll do the Lion King again.
Oh, wait, I'm behind you.
Oh, wait.
For those who missed out on the maid cafe experience, we'll
recreate it i can't get in front of you she does this our
actual height we always have to get boost your c4 okay i'm
back anyway i'll send it to you later i'll send you their
song okay cool thank you so much thank you who here watches
idols i'm sure you're here for the right reason so and our
next question um the first one is for mid bye no bye no
fight no bye bye bye can't nature No bye, no bye, no bye,
bye, bye, can't be too late.
Yay!
I also wanted to ask, what's one thing that both of you do
when things are really tough and you're feeling down?
Wow, seriously.
I play Marvel Arrivals.
I just do queue my sadness away.
Oh, I did.
I think I pet my cats.
Oh, that's cute.
I have a dog.
I should do that too.
That's more like therapeutic than MQ and Riley's.
Get pet and pet them for happiness.
Yippee!
I think one of those might be a little healthier than the
other.
Not that I'm judging, but you know that great 3am
notification of Doki Bird is now streaming Marvel Bibles.
I love it.
And Shereen goes out.
for six to seven hours.
Oh, my God.
Why would you say that?
And our next question.
Hi, Doki.
Hi, Mint.
Hi.
In your guys' opinion, which one of you would you consider
more Sundere than the other?
I can see the loading symbol on your guys' heads.
Like thinking.
Sundere.
I don't think I'm Sundere.
I don't think so either.
I'm not, right?
What do you mean X?
What did you do with that?
It's not like a thank you or you need things that we're
going to say.
Win claims to hate us, but then she keeps coming back and
says that she misses us.
That's so true!
They're always like, Midman says, you're like, I don't hate
you guys!
That's so true.
You're more senior.
No!
But Doki's Gatmoi is pretty good.
Whoa!
Yeah, that's me.
I got the better one.
It's not about Gatmoi.
No!
It's too, didn't.
I don't know!
Yeah, you're being through there right now.
You're not through there, right?
That's like, no!
I mean, I remember the chance of she hates us at the Phantom
Thief concert, so.
But you guys decided that.
I never said that.
You embraced it.
I embraced it.
And thank you so much.
Thank you.
Wow, we got a long line of people for questions.
Okay, let's keep going through this.
How are you guys doing?
Good for more questions?
Yeah, it's awesome.
Wait, when are we, when do we, when does this end?
It's like in 20 minutes, I think.
Oh, okay.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Hello, I'm Conan, named after basically every Conan you can
think of.
Conan and Brian!
Conan!
Detective Conan!
Right!
The comedian, the author of Sherlock Holmes.
Oh yeah!
Apparently it's an old Gaelic term as well, but I doubt that
one.
My question for the both of you is that if you had to force
the other to play a game that you know they would hate the
most, what would it be because I'm trying to get ideas for
the next charity stream?
Hey!
But then we never do charity again.
F them kids.
Wait, oh, what do you not like, Doki?
Tell me now.
I'm singing.
Why would I tell you?
You said it gets me.
I guess I would, oh, I feel like I would make you, I don't
make you play like a real, like a thinking game.
I like the game.
Yeah.
Like, what was it called?
The witness?
No!
Is that...
Wait, oh, the witness?
I heard that's crazy.
I know my answer though.
Yeah, what's yours?
Mine is the mystery of the druids but without a walkthrough.
Oh!
The mystery of the druids?
Yes!
The mystery of...
What even is this game?
You can play...
What is this guy?
This guy's screaming.
You can play it without a walkthrough.
then then did you play it yeah I played it I streamed it oh
okay then the soft puzzle surrounding a mysterious order of
druids oh my god it has mixed reviews let's look at the mega
reviews it's probably like because the game is awesome it's
probably like oh the druid face does not appear in the game
collector icon therefore you cannot fill your profile with
these hot and salty memes cannot recommend the guy with the
face the guy screaming you can't collect him apparently oh
okay wait what's your game though pick again i pick the
witness yeah i'll stream it okay for free not even for like
i'll do it not even for charity i'm the charity awesome
thank you so much I think it's hilarious that you said F
Charity two days before Christmas three days before
Christmas.
That is messed up.
I didn't say it.
I don't say it.
I didn't say anything.
Excuse me, I do not associate it.
It was deep fake.
Not yet a deep AI view.
It was Sora AI.
And her own Q&A is Sora.
Amazing.
me to type the question out that's why they ask you to get
the question in and then they type the prom and the soros a
week are we real yeah are we even real yeah as real as
youtubers could be truly and our next question hi hi I was
wondering between like doing concerts and like video
tournaments and like all And he was like, are you guys like
do all these like projects and stuff like getting
overwhelmed?
I'm overwhelmed.
Oh, yeah, yeah.
I remember you said when you're scheduled, you're like, oh,
I can fit another stream in.
I was like, you are not fitting another stream into that
schedule.
It was like literally like starts in the morning and then
you're like at 10 p.m.
You're like, after this meeting, I can do a stream at this
time, but you are not.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
We just, um, I don't know, I just, I'm vibing.
I disassociate.
Yeah.
We're probably like not very healthy examples.
It's not very healthy.
We're not very healthy.
Do not learn from us.
Don't learn from us.
Don't take, don't follow us.
I mean, do follow us on YouTube and Twitter.
Twitter and Twitch.
Twitch.
You have a TikTok?
Yeah, a TikTok.
Yeah.
I just post my shorts there.
You know, since I'm already post shirts and YouTube.
Apparently we should get Instagram now, too.
Like, that's what all the zoomers do now.
They're all on the Insta.
Would you guys follow us on Instagram?
Yeah, would you follow us on Insta?
Yeah.
Yeah, thank you so much.
Thank you.
I love that both of your coping mechanisms are incredibly
healthy and really great.
Woo, let's go.
Those are my, oh, she's right there, guys.
And our next question.
Okay, so I got two.
Doki, can I steal your cutout?
My cutout?
Wait, no, don't do it.
You can buy it though.
How much?
Wait, we'll do an auction.
We'll do an auction right now.
Do I hear a hundred dollars?
Do I hear...
You have a cut up, man?
Yeah, I'm going to go sign yours.
Oh, yeah, you can get a vandalizer, actually.
I'm going to go vandalize here.
That's good.
It increases the value, man.
It increases the value.
Yeah, you can sign it.
Okay, I can.
You can get a donkey bird cut out signed by me.
Yeah, yeah, signed by me.
I think the real question is, what's the max amount you're
willing to pay for it?
You know, for charity.
I'm the charity.
But second one, real quick, for both of you.
Can I take a selfie real quick?
Yeah!
Yeah, sure.
Get out of here.
Take your cutest faces for the selfie.
Or cursed faces.
Whatever one you prefer.
Most.
so cute oh my gosh awesome thank you thank you thank you I
mean we could have a group photo right after too everyone
that would be yeah who here wants a group photo at the very
end we will definitely do that and our next question Hello,
here's my birthday.
Happy birthday!
Here's my question.
Look at both of you.
What are your hot takes, your hottest takes?
My hottest takes.
Oh, I've done so many hot takes on stream.
I haven't even remembered any of them.
Yeah.
Oh, I'll say one that might trigger some people.
Okay.
That you don't have to play higher than 60 frames per
second.
That one really seems to get me.
Oh no, no, no, no.
You did not, you did not say that.
You did not, you don't know the experience.
It's the easiest, it's the easiest rage bait ever.
That's not even, that's not, it's not a hot ticket.
You don't fuck even, sorry.
You don't want to leave.
We get two, wait, for PG-13, you get two S-Arts and one.
I already breached that.
I get two.
I get two as well.
That's not a, that's not a, she was clearly rage bait.
She doesn't even believe in that statement.
No, I do.
She doesn't says that.
Don't you don't believe in it.
You don't know.
Please, I don't know.
Try, okay, try and play.
Say your heart, Jake.
There's so many people dating.
Have we played above 60 braids before?
Okay, rage bait successful, everyone.
Raise your hand if you agree with me.
Don't enable her.
You know it's a lie.
And Doki, what's your hot take?
I can't remember.
I've done so many hot takes on stream that I can't remember
any of them.
It's like, I feel like a food one is pretty easy.
You have like a food one?
food one yeah like pineapple on pizza you know i mean that's
like a very common though yeah though like i personally just
don't like pineapple because they're like they're like
supposed to be so acidic that you're like eating you from
the inside weak skill issue skill issue yeah let me like
mess up my stomach i ate two lemons yesterday why with the
right just a full on lemons yeah yeah Like you didn't have
it with anything else.
You just like bite into a lemon.
Yeah What's wrong with you?
Alright, so here's my welcome.
Final message.
You are awesome jewels.
If y'all were in a team, Yoki, you would be a good tank and
Min Y'all would be a good support.
I can take it.
you're all the way in the background
thank you happy birthday thank you so much happy birthday
whoo whoo and our next question here we go hi howdy howdy
howdy howdy howdy howdy hi doki hi dintos hi uh i just want
to like thank you for being in the anime woman internet of
course yes yeah so real quickly uh since we're in like a
family con uh can you give us apparently uh can you give us
the like lightest uh call me out no hear me out yeah you
have like the uh the tamis hear me out team y'all have tamis
hear me out yeah famous hear me out and not star scream oh
oh like those types of hear me out oh okay i'll just say
like wait what's wrong why can't we choose star scream i
don't know yeah why are we discriminating against is it
because he's a robot megatron megatron yeah he's my like my
second favorite transformers so that's a good choice okay i
mean the obvious choice is like hear me out it's all
transformers like this is just a transformer theme now well
and we're talking about transformers i it's not really a
hero video i feel like everyone agrees the rakia obviously
yeah like she awakens a lot of people's like some people
were watching that as a kid and we're just like this is whoa
my heart get your heart yeah your family friendly guys Yeah,
I would say Megatron, though.
I feel like that's tame.
Megatron?
Yeah, I'm tame.
I mean, I said Herakia.
She's not tame, but...
It's not like it's Transformers thingy, but that's okay.
Just one last thing.
Carol, like, half of the green and yellow women, can you
give a shout-out to Brazil?
Yeah.
Brazil, Brazil, Brazil, Brazil, Bamba!
Shout-out to Brazil!
Thank you.
Awesome.
Thank you so much.
I love how you immediately got lectured for a family
friendly convention and then proceeded to, you know, toe the
edge again.
Did we?
We were answering a question.
Yeah, I think that's on the bodyguards for not checking the
question.
Hey, our bodyguards are working very hard.
and doing a great job so anyways our next question hello
riddle me this wait i thought you were the riddler oh i
thought you were the onesler i'm so sorry not everyone that
wears green is the onesler man i mean i see your i see your
tie now i see it yeah you look great You mean the hat is
literally the, it's the Riddler hat, but you recognize the
tie?
The tie has the question marks on it!
Okay, what's your question?
I'm so sorry.
I was advised not to let on, so the next question.
Have either of you played Dungeons & Dragons before?
Dungeons & Dragons?
Oh, I was in a stream for P&D.
Ooh!
Yeah, how about you?
I played like two times before.
Like off-stream or on-stream?
Like one time off stream and one time on stream.
What was your character?
I don't remember.
I forgot my character's name.
I remember it was like, it was, oh, Rochella.
Her name was Rochella because she's a bard and she's like a
cockroach for a cockroach bard.
And so it was a parody of Cochella.
So I call it Rochella.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah, I don't remember my characters, but yeah.
I would play again.
It's fun.
Yeah, I would love to do it again.
Like a campaign or something.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think I'm a terrible role player though.
I think so too.
Oh, you think, wait, are you saying you think I'm a terrible
role player?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That could be a very fun potential charity stream option.
maybe just giving you guys ideas doesn't like charity I
didn't say that you were like you said you said you said
something about children I said I said I said that I love
charity literally next to you sitting right there and
filming this entire panel we can roll it roll it back yeah
roll it back yeah roll it back you one jay recorded in 4k we
got this yeah awesome thank you so much for your question
and on to our next question uh hi dopey i met you last year
i was spider i don't know if you remember i was spider-man i
only made you for like a year i went to your uh anime expo
concert I think I was last year, this year as well.
Uh, one thing.
Do you think it would be funny to move your collarbone like
a few centimeters as like a joke?
See if anybody in the pad would ever like notice it and be
like, there's nothing wrong.
It's like how like whoever that person was that made my neck
a little bit taller every day.
Like see if anyone noticed.
Mommy, you're watching me!
I feel like it would be hard to notice that.
The collarbone?
Yeah, the collarbone.
Why don't we just remove the collarbone?
Like, it's just gone.
Gone.
Reduced that.
She's got no bones.
Yeah, I got no bones.
I'm just made of boo.
Welcome to the club.
Hold this chicken.
Let it be fine if I take a selfie with you guys.
Of course!
Yeah, of course.
And look how...
cute they are.
Man, I want a picture too.
I'll maybe get one later, winky face.
Yeah, of course.
Thank you so much.
I'm just saying as a big dokeybird fan and simp, I would
notice your collarbones being gone because I'm always
looking at them, but you know.
Whoa!
Yeah, that's why I have my shirts.
My buttons aren't fully
You're cold, you're cold, but in the mood.
Yeah.
It's like a Victorian era.
Oh my gosh, she's showing some skin.
The collarbone.
What does that mean for me now?
You the misbehavior.
Your whole fucking chest is shown.
I don't know your ribbon.
I know.
I have so much.
Yeah.
The Victorian children would be called.
Yeah, the Victorian.
It was baked.
You'll be burned for me.
A witch.
She's showing too much skin.
Burn her.
Awesome.
And on to our next question.
Hello.
My question is, do you think anytime in the future we'll see
the return of WrestleTuber?
Oh, yes.
Okay.
So obviously this year might not have been, I know I can
say, don't worry, this year we'll have WrestleTuber.
There was a lot of stuff going on this year.
But there are plans right now for next, for real, next year,
guys.
So don't worry.
I know this year, don't worry, guys.
We have plans for it this year, but it ended up being really
bad for me when it came to a lot of stuff going on.
So I had to postpone it to next year, but next year there
will be WrestleMania 2026.
2026.
WrestleMania.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
And so we're getting close to the end.
We're only going to do two or three more questions, just
letting you guys know.
it but as again there's a concert coming up soon so make
sure you go to it i'm seeing literally all of your faces
right now and i better see them in the audience and if
you're not going i'm hosting project zomboid if you want if
you want to play project zomboid with me i'm hosting a
survey but we've got no not much time and for the sake of
vte and holiday montori please come to the concert stream is
not amazing.
And our next question.
Yes.
Hi, Mint and Jogi.
Hi.
It's really great to see you both here at a holiday mess.
I have a question from Mint.
Yes.
It made me the same as what you said earlier, but you really
inspired me to actually try Metal Gear with your stream on
Thursday.
Which game do you recommend I start with?
Metal Gear Solid.
The first one.
It's Metal Gear Solid.
I should say they're all Metal Gear.
It's just Metal Gear Solid.
Yeah, don't go for Metal...
Well, I mean, you could go for Metal Gear 1 and 2 without
the Solid.
But Metal Gear Solid!
Wait, there's a difference between Metal Gear Solid 1 and
Metal Gear Solid?
Yes.
What?
Which one is first?
Metal Gear.
Wait, there's a Metal Gear game too?
What do you think you're playing, Doki?
Oh my god.
Okay, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Like, okay, so there's Metal Gear, Metal Gear Solid, Metal
Gear Solid, whoo, okay, okay, no, it's Kojima, there's
Kojima.
But yeah, Metal Gear Solid.
Awesome, thank you so much.
I do want to let you know a bunch of people were putting a
five in the audience.
I didn't see that.
I'm going to kill you all.
I'm going to kill you myself.
That's where we got it.
At this lovely family-friendly convention.
I'm on Minecraft.
Yeah.
She should log in right now.
And on to our next question.
Hi, guys.
I'm more of a casual streamer or a casual watcher, honestly,
but it is really cool to see you guys.
My question is, if you guys are in a 1v2 or 2v2, you can tag
in one fictional character, who wins, and who are you
picking?
Goku.
That was so cool.
wait who's a bear is bear is bear is really a god okay he's
stronger than goku no no no it's literally the cat is
literally the cat god you're done everybody knows goku
always wins goku does not always win he died throughout the
old age man
I died and I'm still here.
They're like, lose the bean.
Go, go, go, eat that bean.
Yum, yum, go back into the fight.
Like, don't worry, we'll wish you
more because he'll come back.
He said he never dies.
His whole thing is he dies.
And then he dies.
Thank you for your question.
Thank you so much.
And real quick, I think maybe we do like a little fan vote.
Okay, so we'll cheer.
So whoever thinks Mint, Mint Goku would win.
hear a loud cheer.
And whoever thinks Doki's pairs would win.
I'm not gonna lie.
I think the Goku cheer was a little louder.
He says he has pretty privilege.
My man doesn't even have pupils.
Pretty privilege.
Anyways, thank you for the question.
And on to our last and final question.
Oh hello!
Hi Min, hi Doki.
I'm Virgil.
So I actually also have a fighting question.
You two are in a street fight real quick.
What special, dirty, underhanded, borderline illegal move do
you use on each other?
I use one of the idols as a mischievous.
That's dirty.
That is dirty.
I think I lost.
Yeah, I think she loses that.
I don't know, I might activate like something maternal in
me.
So I have to like protect her.
You're manhandling her.
That's why you talk super saiyan.
Yeah, that's...
You're like, let her go!
My secret dirty, unhanded trick that I would use is
mid-battle.
Right before I lose, I do discover that there's some secret
power within me.
unlocks and i become the shonen protagonist and then i i do
like a barrel roll through the sky and i triple last like
seven episodes and i win i would recommend everybody to try
that you keep like becoming the main character yeah yeah
yeah my dirty underhanded trick is that i became the main
character just discover the power within you.
Just like raise your heads everyone give us the power for
the spirit bomb.
Awesome thank you so much the panel was so fun and amazing
and those questions were awesome.
Thank you!
Thank you everybody!
Thank you all for coming to our panel.
Sorry we couldn't get to every question sorry we laughed so
much.
And I think we have time for a group photo.
Thanks for fun.
everyone come up very carefully please do not push go over
anything like that